a couple in puerto rico has an important
message to share chris gonzalez and
sophia gerald both have far exceeded
expectations and they want others to
know they can do the same regardless of
their circumstances our lead national
correspondent david bagno traveled to
puerto rico to meet the couple and see
how they've dealt with major challenges
david good morning good morning to you
this is a celebration of two people who
were born with special needs and are
doing extraordinary things dreaming
defying doubts
they have become the joy of their island
and i'm telling you by the end of this
story you will be standing up cheering
them on like we are watch
[Music]
and with that our conversation began
with sofia hirao and chris gonzalez
to meet them we flew to the isla de
lancanto the island of enchantment
puerto rico
you could say that they are redefining
the meaning of the term power couple
they were both born with down syndrome
and are now promoting a campaign called
sin limitus without limits and let me
tell you they are inspiring the entire
island
chris who is this
my good friend sophia sophia
and who is this it's my boyfriend roy
i love driving
according to chris's parents in 2014 he
became the first person with down
syndrome on the island of puerto rico to
get a driver's license
the 25 year old also loves to cook and
today he runs his own food truck to
spray it okay
gonzalez's dad eugene told us he is in
awe of his son's drive to succeed
i know you're proud of him oh definitely
he's
he's so um
persistent
he makes us be a better person maybe
he'll
a couple of times he'll fail but he
knows that he has to try and try again i
guess that's what we've learned from him
that's a big lesson in life that's a
good lesson for all definitely chris how
does it feel to hear your dad
talking
so positively about you i'm so happy
he's so proud of you
i'm trying to hold back the tears here
tell me what's going through your head
it's hard to explain
seeing him
with everything that he's accomplished
has been hard for him
but
he's doing it
he's not only a trained chef he's a
barista too
in fact he's added retail entrepreneur
to his resume with his own brand of
coffee i have
off my coffee what do you have
that new coffee this is for me yes well
thank you chris and
my girlfriend
and look what it says chris seen
limitless
chris without limits
he now made history earlier this year as
the first woman with down syndrome to
model for victoria's secret
secret i love it and she's also taken to
the catwalk at new york's fashion week i
love mother i love cameron you like the
camera yeah
i love camaron
thanks to the success of her modeling
career the 25 year old also has a deal
with the cosmetic giant l'oreal and she
is also building her own brand with the
support of her mother mimi she's working
on a fashion line tell me about this
little blessing in your life
she is a blessing she's a happy person
she brings joy to everyone do people
stop you because they recognize you see
yeah
yeah do they take a picture with you
yeah yeah
as a model and a businesswoman hidal
understands the importance of staying in
shape we were with her we saw she's in
the gym regularly five days a week doing
an hour every day you know she's also a
social media influencer she's got more
than six hundred thousand followers on
instagram
to see the two of them together is
really special
and although they live on opposite ends
of the island more than two hours away
from each other they have a standing
date it's a daily facetime call that
we're told can last up to three hours
just to be clear sophia you live in san
juan yeah i live in san juan puerto rico
and chris you live in rincon yes on the
western side of the island yes
yes they may be separated by distance
but when we were there we saw that they
are inspiring each other
living their best lives and continuing
to grow as individuals
following their dreams shattering
stereotypes and embracing success
and each other
they're setting an example for the rest
of us to live life
without limits
i could feel you building to that last
line without limits
i knew it was coming but i was going to
say it if you weren't going to say it
because they really personify that right
with the driver's license with the food
truck with all of their jobs it's an
amazing story look you and i both um
have ants right with special needs and
so i have a special place in my heart
for people who have special needs but in
fact they're simply just special people
and their ability to bring joy to other
people is what we wanted to share this
with also the parents you think about
this yes not setting the limit forget
defying expectations don't set the limit
don't set the limit you know dana chris
lives on his own found an apartment sort
of built it up sophia is still living
with her parents but i think the two of
them could live independently if they
wanted them to and their parents deserve
so much credit for setting them up like
that by the way chris turns 26 on friday
happy birthday buddy happy birthday
chris yeah redefining what it is to live
life without limits thank you that's a
beautiful story dave thank you very much
again thank you again